thank you alejandro yes i'm here with
mvl
after what uh it was once again a wild
affair between him and fabiano
what's up with you guys you always play
some theoretical
monster juggernaut of games um
yeah i know fabi you know is fighting
players so i like to play him and
but i was happy until he told me right
after the game that
i had mixed up the move orders uh
so here yeah it goes up g5
first and um did you expect him to play
this line
yeah i looked at this but yeah for some
reason i thought
if i was not possible here like because
of some rocky 5
but other just a further
apparently yeah so i just thought it's
f4 right away from my memory but
my memory was 40 and i mean i realized
that here
you know queen exceeds was by no means
first
but you know i mean i was i had to take
it
and yeah so apparently
here is the moment um
yeah like this he was a mistake queen of
six
i don't know for some reason i thought
this was okay for me but
yeah 93 and i d5
ah yes simply this is simply this way
just a easy way to open up the airflow i
mean i'm not surprised that you know
once i know that this was a mix-up in
move orders i'm not surprised that this
their house was just for me yeah um
yeah so i guess i can say i'm a little
fortunate yeah i mean i
i was a bit annoyed that i don't have
anything better than
making a draw but i thought even like if
i start to push it
a bit too much like h4 i was considering
but there are d2 here
and i d2 you have queen is hitchhiking
and
this could get for example actually
queen e1 so if you
try to run away yeah king h1
no you can take on e5 first and then
take on h4
you you're winning zoom you're winning
the night after queen h2
there's no way to uh yeah and yeah this
is would be a draw but
you know as i have zero chance of
winning
uh i thought bishop f4 is much safer
absolutely and uh
what is your strategy for the next three
games obviously
the tournament is not going your way
remembering my lines
fully and accurately this would be a
good start
i thought i did today but turns out i
didn't so
there's still lots of work to do in that
respect
yeah i guess i calculated quite all
right then considering the difficult
circumstances and
thinking that i was still you know doing
fine where
i might not be so yeah i mean
we'll see what i can come up with
tomorrow awesome thank you very much uh
maxim we're looking forward to see some
more explosive games from you yeah thank
you guys thank you maxime
uh an honest man i mixed up my lines